our next guest is a hilarious
amazing talented actress who we all know
and love for her high jinks and straight
face humor from so many things including
parks and rec and now she's the author
of a children's book called the legend
of the christmas witch please welcome
the illustrious aubrey plaza
[Applause]
meets a witch thank you very much i'm a
high fashion witch and i'm happy to be
here i mean
you really are you're giving me meow
fall like i am winter coat tour
collection 2021. yes you're so cool no
like i'm so we saw each other the other
night at the cfca yes um i saw you and
we freaked out on each other and i was
like we're gonna be together next week
i know and you looked beautiful and you
were um you were like an orb like i had
a baby
christian siriano
like dream dress
but you're such a fashionista like a lot
of people like watch your moves okay
yeah it's true i mean i guess i'll just
say that i'm definitely like into this
whole like early 90s resurgence um just
because that's how i grew up so
um like when i was younger like i would
wear my mom's um
like s skirt suits sometimes to school
yeah like a sensible skirt exactly yeah
and the vest like i'm into i'm yeah i'm
into the like like business core sure
yes i love how core is now
makes it a thing
like your witch core right
totally which core you are so rich
specifically the christmas witch core
okay so the christmas witch i'm so
excited for this book what inspired you
to write this christmas witch book with
your partner
dan yes dan and i um who is my writing
partner who
is my best friend and who i've known
since i was 16 years old
we we've always had a dream to like make
movies together we went to film school
together which was a coincidence and
part of the idea came because i love
halloween and every year i dress up like
a witch but like a scary witch like
really terrifying looking
and i do a whole performance piece
outside of my house where like the
kitties come and i throw candy at them
and i scare them like i i hide behind i
i have this like fake um cemetery with
these tombstones that i actually keep up
all year
um
just because how did this transpire how
did that part
uh manifest the halloween thing because
i think i've always had like a thing
about like screaming in in public like
really loudly
um or like you like it yeah you want to
do it yeah
and do you want to do it because it's
not
it's not appropriate i don't know like i
think i just when i was growing up i
always had like um just like an ur i
think i went to an all girls like
catholic school that was like very
conservative i think i just always had
like this like
like seething rage that's like
uh very deep um inside of me and i
think that
that like i just have always like you
know andy kaufman like you people that i
love andy kaufman yeah so it's like um
i've just always been fascinated with
like disrupting
like
normalcy in public like public stunts
like i would dress up like a chicken and
i would go
outside on the highway and like
bounce a ball like just for the
passerbys
and just
just to see like are they going to be
like whoa what is that or are they just
going to go i'm not i didn't see it i'm
just driving um so anyway i think i've
always been like kind of um yeah just
interested in like just shenanigans or
something well your sister happens to be
here in the audience yes
um and i'd like to know what was aubrey
like growing up oh my god
don't oh yes
this is a terrible idea speaking of
disrupting normalcy that uh same school
that aubrey went to for so long i also
went to yes she did there's a 12-year
difference between us so she would drive
me to school in her bright red mini
cooper with a football helmet on i
need you and that cackling happened all
the way with the football helmet on i
love that you're lying
[Laughter]
don't do this
i have more
all right renee oh my god like when
you're growing up and you have this
older sister and you're looking up to
her are you like
i wish i had a normal straight laced
like sister are you like
thank god i have this entertaining cool
interesting
human being in my family or somewhere in
between
it's probably somewhere in between i
mean because we went to the same school
she kind of put that
normalcy disruption into my existence in
that school yes i will say that renee
has carried the torch um
i used to dress up like in a lot of
costumes and do shenanigans at school
and then renee
also did that um we were both the school
mascot
which we which wasn't like a actual
thing we just made it up
so
yeah it runs on that family i guess yeah
what was the mascot well the original
mascot was the was the ursuline raider
it's called ursuline academy but um i
think what i i don't you remember what
you wore but what i wore was like uh
goggles a cape um
a beehive net
um like a beekeepers yes
and just whatever i could find around
the house i put it all in my trunk and
then i'd drive around to the games i'd
throw it on and i just yeah run around
and i wish you were my sister
[Music]
you